Speaker 1: I want to start today with some
genuinely good economic news, and the news itself
is a very small data point. But there's a bigger
story here, and it's the story first and foremost
about how is the economy doing right now. That
gets us to what will the impact of the economy be
on the midterms. If people accurately understand
the state of the economy because it's about the
perception of the economy more than the economy
itself, that affects how people vote. And then
the bigger conversation, which I think continues
to be a very interesting one, is what in general
can we say about the state of the American economy
when there's a Democrat in the White House versus
when there is a Republican in the White House? So
come along for the journey. Let's you know, rather
than starting at 30,000 feet and getting down to
the runway. Excuse the analogy. Let's start at the
base and then get up to 30,000 feet. So economic
news, good news, GDP has accelerated in the United
States at 2.6% in the third quarter. We just
got these numbers. Remember, the third quarter
is July, August, September. And we get those
numbers at the end of the following month, which
is now the end of October. Expectation for GDP
growth was 2.3%. The actual number was 2.6%. So
having an increase rather than a decrease by
standard economic metrics where we want indefinite
growth, I know it's good to have GDP growth and
then when it is better than the expectation,
then it is considered even better. And indeed,
the stock market is reacting to this quite
favorably as of this particular moment when we
are filming, the Dow Jones Industrial Average
is up over 500 points and we will see where the
day finishes out. A narrowing trade deficit and
increases in consumer spending and government
outlays boosted the number all normal. A sharp
pullback in housing subtracted from the number
part of a broader decline in private investment.
Consumer spending decelerated, increasing at
just a 1.4% pace in the quarter, down from 2%.
So understand that oftentimes the reports on
this stuff are so unclear, consumer spending
decelerated. Might make some think that consumer
spending is down. It is not. It grew at a slightly
lower rate than in the previous quarter. So the
obvious question when we get such numbers is
this must be terrible for Democrats, right? How
will Democrats and Joe Biden ever survive this?
Obviously good news. That's a joke. One of my
followers on Twitter said something like, The way
Fox News will report it is, is the economy doing
better right now because people expect Republicans
to take over in November. So they are spending
now because they know the economy will be better
once republic. It's a joke, but it wouldn't be
completely foreign to Fox News to pull something
like that. So that's the GDP number nets.
Let's now take a look at the broader economy.
We have an economy where we have better than
expected GDP growth. Historically low unemployment
to the point where one could argue we are within
a few tenths of a point of what we would consider
full employment. Remember, full employment isn't
every single person has a job, but by the economic
definition of full employment, we're very close to
that. Consumer demand continues to grow, albeit at
a slightly slower rate than it did in the second
quarter. And there is still high inflation. Of
course, there's no there's no need to exclude
that from our analysis or to pretend that that's
not going on. So it's becoming very difficult to
make the case that this is a terrible economy, but
Republicans are still doing it, and that's what
gets us to the impact on the November election.
There was a point. Eight weeks ago, ten weeks ago,
something like that, where the number of Americans
who said abortion access and the overturning of
Roe v Wade are top issues in terms of the midterms
that has diminished and has been supplanted
by the economy, which at the end of the day,
in most elections, it's the economy that
regularly rates as the most important issue. Now,
sensible people, like many of you would say, well,
David, the the economy's doing well. Most economic
indicators are very good. Inflation's high, but
everything else looks great. Clearly, on the
strength of the economy, Democrats are going to do
really well in November. Right. Not necessarily.
What matters is the perception of the economy. And
by straight up telling lies and focusing only on
inflation. Republicans have convinced many voters
that we have a bad economy right now. Nearly full
employment. GDP growth. Choppy, but not crazy.
Stock market. But many voters believe that
there's something very wrong with the economy.
And if indeed they do believe that, it wouldn't
be unexpected for them to vote for Republicans
since they are the out party currently in terms of
power in the White House, House and Senate. This
then gets us to the last thing I want to discuss
a little bit, which is, in general, does the
economy do better under Democratic or Republican
presidents? The data are extraordinarily clear
on this. Don't trust me. Do your own research on
this. But if you look historically in the modern
political era, on average, the stock market does
better under Democratic presidents. Job growth
is stronger under Democratic presidents. The
unemployment rate is lower. Under Democratic
presidents, GDP growth is greater under
Democratic presidents. Inflation is lower under
Democratic presidents. Are there exceptions? Yes.
But that is an undeniable reality. Now you will
often hear talking points from the right when
confronted with this undeniable data, where they
will say things like, Well, that's because a lot
of Democratic presidents had the benefit of a
Republican controlled House to rein them in.
Such statements have been evaluated empirically,
and they are without merit. Sometimes you will
hear, well, there is a lag time. So really
like the first six months of a Democratic
administration are the economic result of the
previous administration, which might have been
a Republican. It's been studied. And there is no
empirical evidence suggesting that. So don't take
my word for it. Unlike many others, I don't tell
you that I hold the ultimate and unique truth or a
monopoly on the data, or a monopoly on evaluating
the data. Do the research yourself. I've done
it myself. I've made the spreadsheets
myself, and I've looked at it closely.
And unless I have lost every ability to interpret
even the most basic data, this is the reality
that I've presented to you. Fact Check me.
Tell me if you find something different.